Putin initiates a conscription to
bolster military Invasion and you at the
Ukraine Mount
counter-offensive Russia President
Vladimir Putin announced a partial
mobilization in Russia which will
require citizens to join the war effort
in Ukraine it's a fully adequate to the
threats we Face namely to protect our
homeland it's sovereignly and
territorial Integrity to ensure the
security of our people and people in the
liberated territories we are talking
about partial mobilization that is only
citizens who are currently in the
reserve will be subject to conscription
and above all those who served in the
armed forces have a certain military
specialty and relevant experience and he
warns the West threat to resort to
nuclear weapons this is not a bluff
Putin issued a warning after accusing
Western countries of resorting to
nuclear blackmail despite non-nato
countries threatening to use nuclear
weapons to those who allow themselves
such statements regarding Russia I want
to remind you and he's only talking
about one person by the way
that our country also has various means
of Destruction and for separate
components and more modern than those of
NATO countries and when the territorial
Integrity of our countries threatened to
protect Russia and our people we will
certainly use all the means at our
disposal it's not a bluff the threat
comes as Russia's protest prospects in
Ukraine are Grim with Putin's military
losing thousands of square miles of
territory to Ukrainian counter-offensive
and by the way he's saying this this is
my idea with this you know we've talked
about this before would you say I'll
kick your ass say that again look what
I'm going to do to you maybe you can get
away with it once twice three if you
keep doing that people are going to be
like dude bro shut up do something right
okay so now to to flip you know flip
that is people are moving out of Russia
at a record-breaking rate so earlier we
were talking about your saying tell me
one other country that's getting the
most people I wanted to kind of talk
about this I said let's just wrap a
Mar-A-Lago conversation Germany they're
leaving Russia no but I'm saying they're
going into Germany they're going all
over the place but they're just leaving
Russia they're worried okay like when we
lived in Iran War was going out like
dude but this could get nuclear our
families were just worried about the
safety of the kids so people were
leaving no matter where they get a
chance to go to they're just leaving so
he's in a very tough situation so now
you gonna look at uh Pearl Harbor and
then what happened FDR and then Truman
goes and calls it and here let's go do
this and drop it and hey we saw what
happened to you know Hiroshima
do you take his threat as a bluff or do
you take it as this guy's got his back
so much against the wall right now that
if there is a guy that would do it it
would be him
I think he should be taken seriously but
I do believe that his own civil unrest
within his own company within his own
country is going to be his ultimate
downfall meaning his own people are
turning on him and are going to continue
to rise up I think that's where NATO and
especially with the United States having
their allies work on the Russian
population to expose him for being just
who he is a Madman I think eventually
will back him down and eventually create
his downfall now with that being said
the reality is right now with him having
the ability to push a button uh you know
the unfortunately Ukraine there's not
much to destroy there right I mean it's
basically a vast Wasteland I mean he's
destroyed basically the the entire
country
um with respect to using nuclear weapons
my biggest concern honestly is not his
ability to carry out that threat my
biggest concern to myself
and to my family and to our to my fellow
Americans is honestly
what would be the response if God help
us all if he was to implement a nuclear
attack because we all know what will
happen if he does it well we can
anticipate what would happen
my biggest concern is what's the
response because once you light that
fuse
we may be looking at a completely
different world than we've ever known
before
you know the difference between the
button and US versus Russia
did you have you seen that article okay
so you know on U.S the button is
controlled by who
president one person he can't push the
button there he needs multiple multiple
approvals from Russia
so Russia's situation is not like what'd
you say boom boom that's U.S that's not
what it is in Russia so that gives a
little bit of comfort to say you have to
convince three or five people whatever
the amount of people is for them to say
we agree that it's time to push the
button so I think for the world that's a
little bit worried it's good that
Russia's button to the nuclear bomb is a
lot more regulated believe it or not as
weird as it sounds than the button in
U.S now you uh do you remember what Tate
had to say about this no you ask Tate
this question you misunderstood me
exactly you said you live in Romania
which is on the border of Ukraine
Ukraine war you're seeing this happening
you know this is when we were in Madrid
doing the interview with Tate and
obviously we didn't talk about Putin for
an extended period of time throughout
that interview but basically you brought
up the term madman and he goes I know
that term gets thrown around a lot
Putin's a Madman is a Madman he's crazy
and he goes no I think he's actually a
rational actor but he he is there to
serve his country Mother Russia he's not
worried about global agendas or poll
numbers he's there for one reason only
to take a term from your president or a
president uh make Russia Great again so
I think I don't think he's a bad man I
think he's a rational actor I don't
think he wants to blow up the world I
don't think he wants to do that at the
same time what I do think he has is a
massive ego and I think he needs an off
ramp to save face right now he's not
winning this war in Ukraine you know the
the EU United States is throwing
billions of dollars to prop up Ukraine
and fight Russia and they're doing an uh
a good job of it and I think if you're
if you're Putin and if you want if
you're the world and you want a safe
world you want to give at least Putin an
opportunity to not look weak and to save
face and give him an off ramp so he
doesn't do anything illogical and he
maintains the rational actor status my
take is though his DNA because of where
he came from is all about deception and
killing and murder KGB KGB and poisoning
and of course doing things and
accidentally jumping out of a window or
doing the most barbaric things of course
I think that's his DNA and and look
madman is you know someone who's crazy I
don't know I think he's very calculated
no doubt no question but very smart very
calculated my biggest or my fear is
because of his DNA he does not have the
ability to think Beyond himself meaning
that in just as Patrick said there's a
layer that insulates him from getting to
that button my concern would be he'll
start knocking off those people and
putting in people in their place to
ultimately get to that button who's a
bigger egomaniac Putin or Trump
well look you see Trump in front of the
camera a lot more than you see Putin
that's for sure so that may just be
well and we're all assuming that this is
a big nuclear weapon he has targeted
nuclear weapons he can launch very small
nuclear attacks and and create Mass
Devastation and listen I don't think
he's a Madman I think he's very
calculated but we are pushing him and
pushing him and pushing imagine how
frustrated he has to be that he can't
take over Ukraine because like Adam said
we're sending 50 60 70 80 100 billion
dollars what do you think he's going to
do we're it's no secret that that we are
fighting a proxy war against Russia on
behalf of Ukraine what do you expect him
to do so what happens when you push a
bully one too many times what happens
the bully goes home goes into his
father's closet gets out his assault
rifle puts it in his backpack and comes
to school the next day and say okay
here's the great equalizer and that's
what we see in these mass shootings and
that's and so be careful pushing Putin
into that corner because that's what are
they happen that's not him being a
Madman that's not him being crazy that's
that's that's our problem we did this we
set this up this is our this is why so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]